>>Gregg Tavares: All right. Let's get started.
Welcome, everybody. I hope you enjoyed the
keynote. This is the WebGL techniques and
performance talk.
My name is Gregg Tavares. I'm a member of
the Chrome team, on the GPU part of that team.
If you're going to tweet about this, we ask
that you add the Chrome hashtag, and also
there's a link up there. That is a Google
Moderator link, where, if you think of questions
during the talk, you can put them on there,
and at the end of the talk, you can put them
on there and we'll take the top questions.
You can also vote on questions. And there's
also two mics if you don't feel like putting
them there. But it might help you remember
your questions.
So how many of you have used WebGL? Raise
the hands.
All right. Good.
How many of you who haven't used WebGL have
used OpenGL with shaders?
All right. Quite a few of you.
Okay. That's good, because this is a 201 talk,
so it's kind of assuming that you've used
WebGL. I'm not going to go into like tiny
little details that you might need to know
if you haven't.
I will give you a short overview of WebGL
so hopefully you'll be able to follow along
even if you've never used WebGL before.
I'm going to go over drawing a lot of objects
and different techniques to optimize that.
I'm also going to go over a few post-processing
techniques, a few general dos and don'ts,
and some tips.
So WebGL, if you guys -- if there's anybody
out there that hasn't used it, it's standard.
It's built into most modern web browsers.
It's not a plug-in and it provides access
to the system's GPU, and so it's actually
really simple.
At a conceptual level, you have two functions
that run on the GPU, and so the whole API,
the WebGL API, is there to help you get all
your data and these two functions set up on
the GPU so you can tell it to run these two
functions for you.
And so those two functions are represented
in green in this diagram.
One is called the vertex shader, and the other
is the fragment shader.
The vertex shader is responsible for processing
your mesh.
So if you've ever seen any 3D or worked in
any 3D, you see that -- like if you've watched
a Pixar "making of" or something like that,
you see that 3D models are made out of vertices
and polygons.
All that data goes in this blue box on the
screen, your buffers, and then through something
called attributes, you describe how that data
is delivered to your vertex shader.
Your vertex shader, as far as WebGL is concerned,
only has one responsibility, and that is to
fill in this global variable called GL position,
and it fills that in in clipped space coordinates.
And I'll explain that in a moment.
You also have something called a fragment
shader, and when the GPU renders your triangles
or your graphics, it calls your fragment shader
and says "What color do you want this pixel?"
And so the fragment shader's only responsibility
is to set this global variable, GL frag color,
with the color you want the next pixel to
be.
Both of those shaders can take some inputs
or parameters, and they're called uniforms
in WebGL, and a vertex shader can pass data
to the fragment shader through something called
varyings.
So you can see that it's fairly simple.
Another thing that I like to point out is
that WebGL is actually a 2D API. Of course
everybody is doing 3D with it, but at a base
level, it's a 2D API.
And I'll show you what I mean.
So the first thing is, this is the simplest
vertex shader you could write. We're just
going to take a position from our buffers
and we're just going to store it in that global
vary I mentioned a moment ago. No math. Nothing
special. Straight into that variable.
This is about the simplest fragment shader
you can write. We're just going to say "Every
pixel is red."
If we give it some data that's already in
clipped space coordinates --
So clipped space coordinates are basically
no matter what size you're rendering, no matter
how large your canvas is, they also go from
negative 1 on the left to positive 1 on the
right, they go from positive 1 on the top
to negative 1 on the bottom.
And so if you give it clipped space data and
say "Draw that," you'll get that result. There's
the data for a square. Here's a square on
the screen.
You're the one who has the 3D. You do that
by modifying your vertex shader. So here's
our original shader on the left. On the right,
we've just added two lines. We've added the
ability to pass in a matrix and we're multiplying
that matrix -- multiplying the position we're
passing in by that matrix before storing it
in that global variable mentioned before.
We can compute that matrix in JavaScript.
So here is some kind of pseudocode. The first
part is computing a prospective matrix. The
prospective matrix is what actually takes
your 3D data and converts it to 2D.
A look-at matrix is what's considered the
camera or the view. It says where the camera
is in the scene.
A world matrix is usually the matrix you use
to orient something in the world and rotate
it and position it.
You multiply all those together and set them
into that matrix uniform, and then if you
call it, you'll get that same data prospected
-- looking like it's prospected in 3D, when
in actuality you took that 3D data and converted
it to 2D by adding your own math.
And so that's the unique thing about WebGL.
It's really 2D. You add the 3D.
And all of WebGL is really about how creatively
you use those two functions, the vertex shader
and the fragment shader.
So I'm going to go over drawing lots of objects.
So let's say we want to draw a hundred objects.
If you want to draw a hundred objects, you
can pretty much do anything. WebGL is pretty
fast and a hundred objects is not going to
tax it. You can use any library that's out
there.
You have a typical model-based library. I
have some pseudocode here.
So assume that I have an array of models,
and this code for each model. It's going to
pull out that model. It's going to call this
function, "use program." That's the function
that uploads your two functions, your vertex
shader and your fragment shader. Together
they're called a program. And uploads those
to the GPU. I have a function here called
"setup attributes" that would tell it how
to use our mesh data, and, you know, that's
representing a bunch of calls into WebGL.
Set up uniforms would set up our parameters.
And then finally, GL draw elements is what
draws that object on the screen.
And so if I show you a sample of that, here
are a hundred objects, and you can see that
-- I don't know if you can see that from a
distance but it's running at about 60 frames
a second, which is about as fast as you're
going to get. Monitors usually refresh at
60 frames per second so you're not going to
go faster than that.
But let's say we want to draw a thousand objects.
So we can use that same technique and try
drawing a thousand objects, and you can see
that we're now down to about 30 frames a second.
It's running slower. So we need to do something
about that. So what can we do?
So one thing to notice is that most apps draw
many instances of a few objects. In this particular
application, there are only three objects.
There's a square -- a cube, a sphere, and
a cone.
And so why am I executing these heavy steps
in my inner loop? And those heavy steps are
these three red steps. "Use GL program" is
a very heavy step. It has to upload your program
to the GPU. "Setup attributes" may have to
call from 15 to 30 GL functions to set up
all your attributes and tell the GPU how to
use your data.
"Set up uniforms" as well could be 5 to 20
calls. And we're doing that a thousand times
every frame, and that's going to add up to
a lot of time.
So what if, instead, for each type of object
-- in this case, we have sphere, cube and
cone -- set up what's common to that and then
for each instance of that type of object,
set up whatever is unique and draw that instance.
And so here is the code changed a little bit.
I sorted my array of models by the model type,
and then I have a variable, "last model,"
that I can remember which model did I just
draw.
And inside my inner loop, I'm checking, "Is
the model I'm about to draw different than
the model I just drew? If so, then I'm going
to set up this program for this new model
and set up the attributes and again, set up
the uniforms, but this time I'm only setting
up shared uniforms."
So for example, shared uniforms in this case
are like the lighting. The lighting is the
same for all thousand of those objects, so
I only need to set it up once.
At the bottom, I'm still calling set uniforms
again, but this time I'm passing in unique
uniforms and in this case, unique uniforms
are like its position in the world and the
color of each object. And so in that particular
case, we went from a thousand times setting
up these things to three, because we only
have three types of objects. And so if I go
back and I run this optimized version, you
can see we're up to 45, 50. It depends.
But definitely better than we were doing at
30.
So that's the first thing you could do when
you optimize.
And that's a pretty generic technique. You
can use it almost anywhere.
One thing to notice, though, is that I was
sorting those thousand objects every frame,
and of course this is just an obvious suggestion,
is that if you can move that sorting outside
of your rendering, maybe do it at setup time
or organize your code so that all your models
are in separate arrays, whatever you can do,
use some kind of insertion sort as you add
and remove objects, whatever you can do to
keep that sorted, you could save yourself
from sorting it at the last moment and keep
your speed up.
But let's say I want to draw 10,000 objects.
So let's use that same technique with 10,000
objects.
So now we're running at five frames a second.
And, you know, five frames a second, yeah,
that's pretty bad, but it depends on the application.
Maybe you're going to do something static
or that doesn't animate all that often and
that's okay. But let's try optimizing it.
So the first thing to notice is how much work
is JavaScript doing. So in our current code,
we have a loop. It's going over 10,000 models,
and for every model, it is computing a world
matrix. That's the first line here where it
says "M4 translation." And M4 is a reference
to a JavaScript math library that I'm using.
And then it's multiplying the world matrix
by the view projection to get a world view
projection and that was the example we showed
at the very beginning when I showed the simple
3D shader. If you want the minimal math in
your -- in your shader, this is what you'd
end up doing in JavaScript.
But those two things represent a lot of work.
So that making a translation matrix is filling
out a 16-element matrix. Multiplying two matrices
is 64 multiplies and 16 adds or something
like that. It's a lot of work. And we're doing
that 10,000 times per frame.
Great.
[Laughter]
Thank you, Microsoft!
[Applause]
I think they did that in intentionally.
[Laughter]
>>> Talk about WebGL support in IE.
>>Gregg Tavares: So WebGL support in IE. Well,
we will hammer our best on Microsoft and convince
them to add it. Until that time, you have
Chrome Frame, if you're running IE, and it
runs great and WebGL performs excellent there.
>>> (Speaker is off microphone).
>>Gregg Tavares: This demo does work in Linux.
>>Gregg Tavares: If I had a Linux machine
set up, I would have considered that.
Sorry about this.
What other questions can you come up with
while we're wasting time?
>>> (Speaker is off microphone).
>>Gregg Tavares: The math library I'm using
is called TLD or 3D library. File it at 3Dlibrary.googlecode.com.
There's also a benchmark. If you search the
WebGL math benchmarks, I'm sure you'll find
one that's kind of comparing these, and it's
getting the different library makers to make
their libraries as fast as possible, and it's
also getting the browser developers to look
at those benchmarks and speed them up.
So obviously all of the browser developers
are trying to be the fastest browser out there.
And we take those very seriously, and we definitely
are speeding them up all the time. I think,
in fact --
I actually had to change my talk in the last
week, because one of my optimizations was
based on JavaScript being slow and V8 got
faster and it no longer made sense.
>>> Which version of (inaudible) based on?
>>Gregg Tavares: WebGL is based on OpenGL
ES 2.0 with zero extensions, so that's pretty
much like the saying, "Well, iPhone and Android
both use OpenGL ES 2.0."
What else uses it? Chrome OS uses it. WebGL
uses it.
It's similar to OpenGL but, OpenGL -- a lot
of things have been removed in OpenGL ES which
make it more streamlined.
Okay. Where were we? So we went through this
optimization, and I was just about to show
you. Right. So before we were doing all this
work, we're doing this -- creating this translation
matrix and doing this multiply that's very
expensive work for JavaScript.
So what if we move that work to the GPU? So
instead of actually generating those matrices
in JavaScript, let's just pass the position
up to the GPU and let the GPU create those
matrices. So we are changing the JavaScript,
so we just give it the position.
Here we are taking the position of one instance
and sending it into a uniform and setting
up the uniforms.
This is how we change the GPU -- or the vertex
shader. So the old vertex shader was multiplying
by the world view projection that we're passing
in. The new vertex shader where we are only
passing in world position, this is the code
that will build a world matrix. This the code
-- Instead, we are going to pass in a view
projection.
This is another advantage. Not only are we
not computing a world view projection in JavaScript
for every one of those 10,000 objects but
the view projection is global. We only have
to pass it in once. It is the same for all
objects. We are saving the time of even passing
it in on top of computing it.
So then you can see at the end where we actually
use it, those lines haven't changed. The only
thing that has changed is whether we have
passed in the world view projection computed
from JavaScript or that we only passed in
a world position, a computed-in line.
So if I show you that example, we were running
at five frames a second before. Now we're
running at about eight -- seven, eight. So
it is running a little bit faster, but that's
not really good enough, right? We want to
do better.
So what are we really doing? Right now we
are drawing 10,000 objects. For every one
of those objects, we are -- currently we are
setting up a world position. Before we were
setting up a world matrix, we are setting
up a color. And then we are calling draw.
We will get it in one of these cubes.
We set up a new world matrix and a new color
and we call draw again and we get another
one of these cubes.
On the left, that represents the cube data.
There is only one cube in memory, a mesh for
one cube, and we're using it to draw multiple
cubes.
What if instead we put all the cubes in one
mesh and we'll add some extra data so we can
actually treat them as though they were separate
meshes.
What do I mean by that? I will take the data
for one cube and instead of just having that
one cube, I'm going to repeat it inside our
buffers basically 10,000 times.
And I'm going to add two more columns of data.
I'm going to add a world position column.
That world position is the same for every
vertex of cube zero and then switches to whatever
the position needs for cube one, but it is
the same for every vertex of cube one.
The same with color. The color is repeated
for every vertex of cube zero, and then it
is repeated again for whatever color cube
one is for every vertex of cube one.
In this example, we were going to draw four
cubes. We ended up being able to draw them
with one draw call. So instead of JavaScript
making four draw calls for four cubes, we
would make one draw call for four cubes. And
that should save us some time.
Again, we have to change our shader. So we
had our old shader. Our new shader we are
passing in -- we are getting our world position
from these buffers. And we're going to compute
the world position by just adding it to the
position of the individual vertices of our
cube at the origin. And, again, we are only
passing in view projections so we save that
time because it is global.
We also have to pass in our color. We are
getting our color out of our buffer, and we
are going to pass it through a varying over
to the fragment shader.
The fragment shader used to have a color that
we passed in where we changed it before each
draw call and passed that in as a uniform.
But now we are getting that from the vertex
shader.
So what this means is there's very little
work going on -- I shouldn't say there is
very little work going on, but we are only
doing a couple draw calls. Actually, that's
one of the things you need to pay attention
for when you are trying to optimize for WebGL.
The fewer draw calls you can make usually
the faster it is going to run.
Here's one thing. We are still updating a
lot of vertices. We have to update the world
position of every vertice for all those 10,000
objects in JavaScript. But let's see how it
does.
So now we are running at 24 frames a second.
That's a lot better than five or eight. That
might be good enough. Let's take it to the
next level.
Let's say we want to draw 40,000 objects.
So we'll use that same technique and we'll
draw 40,000 objects. And we're running at
about 13 frames a second. That's actually
pretty impressive when you think of what's
going on.
I will tell you what I mean. What is JavaScript
actually doing? JavaScript is actually computing
40,000 positions every frame. It's updating
the world position of all the vertices, and
those objects are average of 21 vertices each.
That's 852,000 vertices every frame. That's
2 1/2 million values because every vertice
has an X, Y and Z. It has to update all three.
It was doing it at 15 frames a second. That's
like 37 million operations a second that JavaScript
is doing. I mean, some of those JavaScript
engines are doing -- are pretty amazing.
But let's see if we can make it go even faster.
One of the things we're doing is we're computing
for those 40,000 objects. Each instance of
those objects has a clock in the current limitation.
So you can see here we're updating the clock
in each axis of a particular instance. Each
axis has a speed. Each axis has a clock. We
are taking the elapsed time and advancing
those three clocks.
The way these objects move, they kind of move
in a kind of spherical spirograph function,
which is what this math is doing. Each axis
has a radius. We multiply it by the clock,
and we get the spinning motion that you saw.
The problem with that is that their state
going back here every instance has three clocks.
So there's 120,000 clocks that we're updating
and they say persistent from frame to frame.
What if we have one clock and we compute where
those clocks would be every time we need them?
We have just one clock. Instead, we have an
offset for each of the individual clocks for
all 120,000 clocks. We can take our global
clock. We can multiply it by a speed. We can
add where the clock started. That will give
us the same answer. We're not actually storing
any result. We only need it temporarily, just
long enough to draw.
This math stays exactly the same. But what
does that do for us? If there is no state
in your computation, then you can use that
math to the GPU. So what do we have to do
to do that? We have to add the data we needed.
We will get rid of the world position from
our data because we are going to compute it
now. We're going to add our clock offset,
clock speed and clock radius to our buffers.
Again, they are repeated. So those values
will be repeated for each vertex for a single
cube. And then for the next cube, there will
be unique values for each vertex of that cube.
So here's our shader again. We're back to
our old shader at the top. The new shader
we are going to pass in our clock. We are
going to get our clock offset, speed and radius
from our buffers. And before, like in JavaScript,
we did this in three lines. In the shader,
we can do it in one like because that clock
is a vec3. Vec3 has an X, Y, and a Z. Clock
offset has an X, Y and a Z. Clock speed has
an X, Y and a Z. That's actually doing all
three clocks at once.
This line we're pulling out our spherical
coordinates and putting them in a temporary.
And then we are computing world position.
Again, T has an X, Y and Z. Radius has an
X, Y and a Z. So a lot more is happening there
than was in JavaScript in a single line.
Finally, where we can put in a position, this
is the same code again. It is just what's
changed is how we are computing that at the
beginning.
And so if we do that example,
now you can see we are running 40,000 objects
at 30 frames a second, 40 frames a second.
At this point, almost everything is happening
on the GPU. So this is going to be very GPU-dependent.
If you run it on a desktop, it is probably
going to run at 60 hertz JavaScript is actually
making about 14 draw calls, period. The only
reason it is making 14 instead of one is that
WebGL has a limit of 64,000 polygons per draw
call. That's actually not per draw call. If
you use index primitives, if you know what
that means, then you can only have indices
that are 16 bits. In this particular case,
there are 14 draw calls. That means the CPU
is actually probably sleeping, so you are
not using a whole lot of battery and the GPU
is doing everything for you.
So, to recap those things, in the simple case,
order by model. If you are not ordering by
model now, add that to your library. If you
are using somebody else's library and you're
running up to some performance issues, make
sure they are ordering by model.
If it makes sense, use the GPU for instancing.
So a good example are trees. I don't know
if any of you remember the O3D beach demo.
I have been too lazy to port that to WebGL.
If somebody wants to volunteer, it is open
source. Originally all the trees, the bushes,
the shrubs were all instanced. That had 1500
draw calls to do one frame. To do the reflections
and things like that required another rendering
of the entire scene for 4,500 draw calls.
Instead, we merged all those trees and merged
all those bushes into one large model and
got it down to 70 draw calls. And then, of
course, it sped up significantly.
Another one is tile-based maps. If you are
doing any kind of like platform game or any
kind of old-school game that uses a tile-based
map, if you had a map on the screen and you
were displaying, say, 40 tiles by 20 tiles,
if you want to draw each tile individually,
that's 800 draw calls. Instead, if you use
some of these techniques, you could probably
get it to be one draw call per row and still
be just as flexible and you would get it down
from 800 draw calls to 20. That's a huge optimization.
And then finally visualizations. I don't know
if any of you have seen the WebGL globe that
Google just posted last week. You have a globe
and you have all these little lines that you
want to put all over the Earth or in your
visualization. You could draw every one of
those lines individually, and it would go
very slow. Or you could somehow bake them
into a mesh at run time or offline and get
it to run very fast.
And then, finally, if it makes sense, put
the math in the GPU. If you have ever seen
the field demo on WebGL samples, all that
grass is computed in a GPU, all its motion.
All of that is just math from the GPU. JavaScript
is doing nothing but passing in a clock.
There is a particle library on the WebGL Wiki.
If you haven't seen it, I highly recommend
that you take a look at the code. It is very
flexible. You can put it in your own apps
and you can instantly add particles to your
game with very little work. All those particles,
all the math for them is running on the GPU
so they take very little time and it is very
flexible. You can do flames. You can do smoke.
You can do fog. You can do ripples. You can
do jet exhaust, whatever you need.
Another one is simulations. I don't have a
picture here, but there was a simulation of
every meteor that's been discovered in the
last 50 years. I think it has all 500,000
something meteors. If you wanted to do that,
you could do that very easily by putting all
that data for those meteors into your buffers
and writing a shader that used them, pass
in time what time you want to see the discoveries,
and either show them or don't inside your
shader.
All right. So let's move on to post processing.
What is post processing? Well, post processing
is almost anything you do to a photo in Photoshop.
A few examples, one is blur. I'm not going
to go over blur today because if you want
to see blur, you can go look at the field
demo we wrote last summer. If you press D
for "debug," I think it will show you how
it is blurring and you can look at that code.
Color adjustments is obviously just doing
anything with the colors, like this picture
on the top right, to have the color tweaked.
Persistence is something you wouldn't do in
Photoshop but you might do in After Effects.
I will go into that when I get there.
There is this really cool technique called
color adjusting using a color cube. Basically
you have a cube that represents each color
in a certain axis. We have red across one
axis, green across another, and blue across
the third. If you make one of these color
cubes and adjust it to, say, something like
this and then you use that cube, you can map
an image. We will take a pixel out of the
first image. Let's say it is red. Of course,
in WebGL, colors go from 0 to 1. A pure red
pixel would be 1-0-0. We use that to index
this cube. We go over 1 in the red, 0 in the
green and 0 in the blue we pull that color
out and we use that to draw the image.
To do one more, we pull green out from a palm
frond. This time it is .6 in red, 1.0 in green,
and 0 in blue. Again, we go over .6 in red,
1 in green, which is in the back, and 0 in
blue, which is still the top. We get that
color, and we draw with that color. This is
a great technique. I'm actually not a video
editor, so I don't know if it's in After Effects,
Final Cut Pro or any of those, but I do know
games use this a lot.
One problem, though, WebGL doesn't support
3D textures. But, fortunately, we can simulate
3D textures with 2D textures. I will show
you how to do that.
The first thing is we take every slice of
our 3D texture and we spread it out into a
2D texture.
And then we are going to make a function that
you can use in any shader you want that should
give it that 2D texture. You give it the coordinate
inside the cube you want, in texture coordinates,
and you give it a size.
When I say "size," this size is how many units
there are in the cube. So the cube I'm going
to use in the example is 8 by 8 by 8. This
sample in this case size would be equal to
8.
The first thing we need to know is how big
is one slice. So one slice is obviously -- textures
always are referenced from 0 to 1. One slice
is 1/8 in this case since our size is 8.
We need to know the size of a pixel. A pixel
is one size of the slice divided by the number
of pixels. Again, that's 8.
Now we need to know the size we are going
to interpolate across. We want to interpolate
from the middle of the first pixel to the
middle of the last pixel. So the question
is why do we want to do that? Why not go from
the very left to the far right?
Well, here's the reason. If you have a three-pixel
texture and you use nearest filtering, you
are going to get the image drawn up like that
with no filtering whatsoever. If you turn
filtering on, what you will notice is it only
filters from the middle of the first pixel
to the middle of the last pixel. So if we
used the whole texture, we would get too much
white and too much black when we are remapping.
So we actually want to map from the middle
of the first pixel to the middle of the last
pixel and that's why you have to subtract
half a pixel.
So now that we have that size, we can compute
each slice. If we got passed in a blue of
.6 and our size was 8, we'd figure out from
the math above that we want slice 4.
Slice 5, the next slice, is pretty straightforward.
Just add one.
Then we need to know how far into that slice
to get a color, and so here we're going to
add half a pixel, like we mentioned before,
and then we're going to take our red, which
is in texture coordinate X and we're going
to multiply it by that size that we computed
before to get the right position.
So in this case, if red was .08, you could
see it comes at about the seventh pixel in
that slice.
Now we need to compute the position of each
of the slices, since we want to pull out two
pixels.
And then finally, we actually pull out those
two colors from those two slices, and here
we've added in the Y component, which is green.
And so if it was about .3, you can see we'd
pull those pixels where the two arrows are
pointing.
Finally, we need to mix those two pixels so
this math computes how much to mix them. If
we were passing in a blue of .6, it would
come out with a value of .8, and what .8 means
is that you can think of it as a position
80% of the way between slice 0 and slice 1
or you can think of it as 20% of slice 0 and
80% of slice 1.
And in GL SL, you can do that with one line
called "mix."
So demo time. What does that let us do?
Well, here's a video you might have seen,
and here I am adjusting the hue, say plus
60 degrees, or setting it to all weird shades
of blue with a little bit of yellow, or putting
it to Googley colors. Just some crazy things
there.
Or make it look like it's, you know, some
'80s movie sci-fi thing. Or color negatives
or posterize it.
Or make it supersaturated, or make it sepia.
And another thing you might notice is that
I'm actually blending between two settings.
I'm actually using two cubes at once. I call
that function I just showed you twice to get
the values from two cubes and then I choose
how much to mix them. So each time you pick
a different setting, I interpolate between
those two.
And it doesn't have to be for video. Obviously
you can do this through any 3D scene, anything
you can get into WebGL.
So that's great. But how do you make that
cube?
Well, it turns out that's really easy.
To make those cubes, you just take any photo
and load it into Photoshop or some other video
editing program or image editing program,
and then you take a cube that's been stretched
out and you paste it in the top corner.
And after that, you pick any full-screen adjustment,
and as you adjust, you'll notice that it actually
adjusted the colors of that cube, and that's
exactly the cube you needed.
You just take that texture out, and you'll
get what you needed to make those -- that
effect, get the same adjustment that you made.
Now, one thing here is that if you wanted
to save time -- and you guys are making apps
for millions of users -- you probably want
to have the minimal amount of data. You would
probably at this point take that image and
crop it just to that cube, so you can load
that into WebGL.
On the other hand, in WebGL, you have a whole
library, you have the canvas 2D library, and
if you don't really care about the space -- and
these images aren't that big; I think they're
like, you know, 60K or something like that
uncropped -- then you could load that in and
this is what I do in the sample. I load that
in and then using the canvas API, I just pull
out the top 64-by-8.
The reason I do that is that when I go to
inspect my images, I actually have an image
there and I can see what the effect is. If
it was just the cube, then it would be kind
of hard to tell what that's really going to
turn into. So I kind of like that, so I thought
I'd pass that on.
Okay. Let's go on to the next effect. This
is persistence, and persistence is best explained
with a demo, so we'll do the demo first.
Persistence is adding a persistence. So you
can see that these images with no persistence
on this side are very sharp and if I bring
it over here, they start getting all blurry.
So I'll show you how to do that effect.
So the first thing is, we want to create three
framebuffers.
I'm going can to call them new frame, framebuffer
1, and framebuffer 2.
And the steps are, we draw to a new frame.
We draw our normal scene that we didn't have
persistence in to this new frame.
We blend the new frame with framebuffer 1
into framebuffer 2. Then we draw framebuffer
2 into the canvas and then we're going to
swap those two framebuffers and repeat.
So I'll give you a diagram.
Here's our new frame.
We drew our scene. Our scene in this case
is just a blue circle. It's in the top left
corner.
Here's framebuffer 1 in the first frame of
our simulation, of our app. It has nothing
in it.
So we blend those two 50% each. We're going
to get this in framebuffer 2.
And then finally we need to copy that result
to the screen by copying to the canvas.
And now we're going to swap framebuffer 1
and framebuffer 2. And by "swap," I just mean
in this second time, we're going to use framebuffer
2 where -- in the first step and we're going
to use framebuffer 1 in the second step.
So here is them swapped. We have a new frame.
We drew a circle in the middle. We have the
old framebuffer 2 that has the circle from
the last frame in it. We're blending those
together into framebuffer 1, so now we have
something with two circles and you can see
they're kind of fading. And we copy that to
the canvas.
We'll do a third frame. Here are the circles
moved to the bottom right. We're blending
with the last framebuffer we used as a destination
before, and you can see now in framebuffer
2 we have the three circles and we copy that
to the canvas.
And so if you play around with that -- right?
-- we have this example working here but we're
copying those canvas directly on top of each
other.
Well, what if we skew how we blend them? We
don't actually blend them directly on top
of each other but we move it a little bit?
So let's say we move it a little bit to left.
We'll start getting kind of a wind effect.
Or move it to the right, depending on how
our persistence is.
We can multiply it and make it kind of look
-- go out. We can rotate it and make it spin.
So what would you use this effect for?
Well, you would use it for things like -- a
good example is Grand Theft Auto. So Grand
Theft Auto uses persistence -- Grand Theft
Auto on the PS2 uses persistence all the time
to try to hide their atrocious frame rate.
They also use it if you drink liquor in that
game. Their character gets drunk and everything
becomes blurry.
If you were doing a platform game, you might
say, "Well, when the person gets to speed
power-up, make everything use this effect
and blur across the screen."
And you can also kind of see, this is how,
you know, probably iTunes or some other things
do their visualizers. They just keep drawing
the stuff on top, so if you want to make some
music visualizers, this is another good technique.
So the things about post-processing, they're
very easy to add at the end of your project.
You might be thinking you don't need them
and then at the last second, you go, "Oh,
I can add some visual pizzazz by using this."
Another great thing to do is that if you guys
are making any canvas 2D applications, there's
a library out there called WebGL2D.JS which
you can Google for, and it implements the
canvas API on top of WebGL.
And so what that means is you could check,
does the user have WebGL? If so, use this.
You don't have to change any code in your
application, but now that it's in WebGL you
can apply these effects.
So it could be that if the user has WebGL,
he gets to play your fancy 2D game with effects,
like maybe the screen goes all radioactive
when he's, you know, invincible or you add
like that kind of blur effect when he's going
really fast, and if he's using the regular
canvas, you skip that.
And the other thing is, it doesn't have to
be used in the entire canvas. In this case,
I was calling post-progressing because I'm
applying it to the entire canvas. But there
are games like Metroid Prime where you have
glasses, goggles, that you look through and
only through those goggles is this effect
applied and, you know, you see infrared inside
the goggles and outside the goggles you don't.
Those kind of games is -- this is how they
do some of those effects.
All right. I'm going to go through a few WebGL
dos and don'ts.
Number one is, never ever call GL get anything
while rendering. And I've seen this in people's
code. You can call -- when you're looking
up uniforms, you need to call get uniform
location, and sometimes if you want to check
for errors, you call GL get error. There's
a few other things you might query out of
GL. You should be doing that all during setup.
That's normal for experienced OpenGL programmers,
that you should never call get anything while
rendering, but if you're new, you might not
have known this. The thing is that that's
normal, right? It's just normal to set up
your code so that you don't need to call it.
One other thing you can do is -- for checking
for errors is there are things we like to
call internally "debug context" and if you
search for WebGL debug context, I'm sure something
will come up. There's one on the WebGL Wiki
if you search for that.
It's a function that wraps the whole WebGL
context so that it calls GL error after every
function, and that makes it very easy to turn
on and off. You can -- when you're debugging,
you can turn that on, see if you get an error,
then turn it off, and you're back to normal.
You didn't have to affect the rest of your
code with all your checks.
And to give you an example, here is our thousand-cube
example before that was running at 30 to 40
hertz. It's now returning at 8 because I'm
calling GL get after every object.
This is kind of similar, and it probably comes
up less often, but don't attach render buffers
while rendering.
And what I mean by that, a good example is
our persistence example. We had two framebuffer
objects, and those framebuffer objects each
have two render buffer objects. Render buffers
are the actual memory that holds their data
and the framebuffer object is just state.
A lot of people will make one framebuffer
object and say two render buffer objects or
two textures and when they need to switch
to what they're going to render to, they will
attach the texture to this framebuffer object,
do some rendering, attach a different one,
and do some rendering.
Well, that attaching is actually a relatively
slow process. A lot of checks have to be made
by GL. Instead, just make two or more framebuffer
objects. The framebuffer objects just hold
state. They hold a combination of render buffers
and textures, and so you can make as many
of them as you want. They don't take a lot
of memory. They're just state. But that means
you can do that all during setup. And when
you do set those up, you also have to call
check framebuffer status to see if they actually
worked. That, is, again, another set call
-- or get call like in the last example and
will really slow your code down. So do this
all during setup and it's all good.
One thing to do do is do use request animation
frame.
Up until this point, if you've done any animation
in JavaScript, even in just regular HTML or
with the canvas, the only way to do it was
with -- was with using set interval or set
time-out.
The problem with those two functions are,
JavaScript and the browser have no way to
know why are you -- why you are using that
function. Maybe you're writing a Gmail type
of app and you are going to check for messages
or you're writing a chat app and you're checking
for new chat things.
And so even when your tab is hidden or it's
off the screen somehow or your window is minimized,
JavaScript or the browser has to call your
function. Because it doesn't know why you're
using it.
So if you're rendering a game and it's off
the screen, you're just going to sit there
and kind of DOS the user's machine. You're
sitting there rendering your game for no reason.
He's not playing it, he's not looking at it,
it's not on the screen.
Whereas if you use set -- if you use request
animation frame, that's specifically for animation.
It only calls you when your canvas is visible,
whether it's scrolled off, whether it's minimized,
whether it's under the tab, and so you won't
DOS the user's machine.
So I kind of like to put it, set interval
or set time-out is for people who hate their
users and request animation frame is for people
who love their users.
The fortunate thing is, it's implemented in
Chrome, it's implemented in FireFox, it's
implemented in Webkit, or will be soon, and
there are wrappers. They're very short. You
can just search Google for request animation
frame and I'm sure you'll find one that will
just work across browsers. They will fall
back to the bad set interval or set time-out
if they have no other option, but they will
use request animation frame in any browser
that implements it, if it's available.
So a few tips.
One, consider stretching the canvas for performance.
This might be obvious, but I think a lot of
people don't notice. The canvas has two actual
sizes. One is the size you actually render
to and one is the size that displays that,
and those are separate.
So in this top example, I'm setting the canvas
size that I want to render to to 512-by-512,
but I'm saying "Display that a hundred percent
of whatever my container is."
And why would you want to do that?
Well, if you're doing something complex -- for
example, the WebGL aquarium -- it has fairly
complex shaders in certain parts, and those
shaders have to run for every pixel to get
rendered.
So if you have a 30-inch monitor and you have
whatever that is, 4 million pixels, well,
that's a lot of work for the GPU to do.
Instead, you can draw it to a much smaller
resolution. The actual aquarium only draws
to 1,024-by-1,024 and then it lets the browser
stretch that canvas. Of course you're going
to get bit of resolution. It's kind of the
like the difference between HD and SD, depending,
but it depends on what you're trying to do.
A lot of times because you have a lot of motion
in your apps, that stuff is hidden. It's a
great way to get more speed. And video does
this all the time, right? We take our small
videos and we make them full-screen. Even
though the resolution in the video isn't the
same size as the screen, it stretches.
The very cool thing about working in WebGL
is that almost all your apps are going to
be 3D, and if you're doing it in 3D, almost
every 3D library uses a function where you
set your prospective matrix -- you set your
projection matrix to a prospective matrix,
and there's also this function called prospective,
and it almost -- and every library takes the
same four arguments, field, view, aspect,
and your Z settings.
To make this work, all you have to do is set
your aspect to those values. You get the canvas
width divided by the canvas height. That's
the size of the browser you're using to display
your canvas, not the size it's using to render
it. And it just works. You didn't change anything.
And you get speed.
Another tip is send your users to getWebGL.org.
And so you -- there are ways to detect if
the browser supports WebGL at all and then
there's also the chance that it can't initialize
WebGL for some reason. Maybe the user's card
is blacklisted or maybe it's out of memory
or for whatever reason, it might not be able
to start it.
In either case, if you send them to getWebGL.org,
we can try to direct them to the best help
for their situation.
And I've seen some libraries kind of doing
it themselves. They're like, "Oh, you can't
run WebGL. Download, you know, Chrome, or
download FireFox."
Well, that's great until I'm running on a
Web OS machine. That information is not going
to be useful to me.
And so the idea is that the Chronos group
runs getWebGL.org, and you can go to their
-- you can go to the WebGL public mailing
list and you can tell them if there's any
issues you want, if you want them to redesign
this or you have some input, but basically
they will try to keep it up-to-date for all
devices.
And that's something that probably every developer
out there is not going to do by themselves.
The last one I'm going to put up is to use
the WebGL inspector. If you haven't seen the
WebGL inspector, it's very much like PIX for
directX or gDEBugger for GL. I won't tell
you what Google uses it for but I will show
you it working.
So here's an app you might have seen that
came out last Thursday. I changed the texture
so it would be easier to visualize. I was
actually asked to review this app to make
sure they weren't doing anything crazy, like
drawing every one of those lines one draw
call at a time. And I looked at the code and
I wasn't exactly sure what it was doing, so
I thought, "I know, I'll try out the WebGL
inspector."
So the WebGL inspector is an extension for
Chrome. There's also a plug-in for FireFox.
And it adds this little icon up here in Chrome.
And so I click that, and it will reload the
page with the inspector installed. And I'll
tell it to capture a frame, and it's captured
every draw call that WebGL made, and you can
step through them down here, and you can see
here's the actual frame on the bottom right
corner. But if I scroll down and I find the
first draw call, which is here, and I click
that, it will redraw the scene just using
those first 17 commands, as I click command
17, and you can see in the bottom right -- it's
kind of hard to see because the lines are
small but that's the globe without the line.
I can also look, "Well, what program was that
using?" Well, I'll control up until I find
the "use program" before that draw call. I'll
click it. Here's the program that was used
to draw it. Here's all the inputs that it
had, and -- as well as the actual source code
for that shader.
I can also like look at the textures. Here's
all the textures that are used. There's only
three. Here's the world texture. It shows
in the bottom right. I could go back to the
trace and I could see that it's setting up
a buffer here. I'll click on that buffer and
it will show that buffer, and potentially
how it was used and all the data in that buffer.
This is a great way to inspect your own program,
find bugs, see what's going on and look at
other people's techniques and see what they
are doing including your own.
And that's pretty much it. All the samples
that I have shown are available now live at
WebGL samples. I put other demos up here.
You could Google for all of those. I didn't
want to put links.
If you have questions, come to the mics to
ask a question.
[ Applause ]
Any questions?
>>> Yeah, hi.
>>Gregg Tavares: Hello.
>>> How can we deal with different platforms
like a Chrome Netbook that has add-on processors,
a desktop that has a full-blown discrete GPU?
>>Gregg Tavares: How can we deal with?
>>> Different GPUs compared to the GPU in
JavaScript?
>>Gregg Tavares: Well, one thing you have
to do -- You mean like the timing, the fact
that they are different speeds or do you mean
the fact they have different capabilities?
So the question was how to deal with different
GPUs. And the easiest way to do that is either
to do something like they do on the PC and
ask people what features they want or to structure
a code. You could do a timing and you could
see is it running too slow and, say, take
some features out.
The other thing you need to do -- It is a
hard question because you could be running
on a desktop that has, say, the highest-end
GPU, the newest one with 2 gig of RAM or you
could be running on a low-end GPU like a G1.
The original Google phones, I don't think
you can even run WebGL.
And I don't really have a good answer for
that other than to either add some options
and say have an SD version and HD version.
Some games do that.
Or, yeah, just structure your code so you
can fall back if you run out of memory. Like,
texture the things that are important first
and the other things that are less important
later.
Yes, sir?
>>> This might be slightly off topic. So I
have been watching the FireFox team implement
WebGL.
>>Gregg Tavares: Okay.
>>> And they have been having a pretty large
share of problems dealing with platform-specific
driver bugs. And while dealing with that,
they've been very active in the driver community,
asking lots of questions, contributing -- filing
upstream bugs.
The Chrome team has been completely silent,
at least from the Linux driver perspective.
And I was wondering if that's simply because
you guys had relatively little challenge with
implementing WebGL or is it just a team policy?
>>Gregg Tavares: So I think the question was
there's been a lot of talk from FireFox about
talking to the various graphic driver manufacturers
about issues with driver stability, in particular
Linux.
>>> Yeah.
>>Gregg Tavares: Or just in general. And you
haven't heard much from Google.
I can tell you that the chairman of the WebGL
group is now Ken Russell, who's on the Chrome
GPU team. And he's probably the most vocal
guy ever. That he isn't being vocal in public,
I think that's just happenstance because he
is very vocal internally and he is very vocal.
I don't think it has crossed his mind he needs
to be more vocal in public, and I will bring
that up with him.
He is heading the charge to get our robustness
stuff into the drivers and to make sure all
these issues are dealt with both for platforms
in general including Linux.
>>> Okay, thank you.
>>> Just a sort of platform-specific question.
Honeycomb tablets with Tegra processors and
video chips, when do you see WebGL making
it to Mobile Web Kit?
>>Gregg Tavares: When do I see -- so the question
is related to tablets and them having good
GPUs, when do we see WebGL making it to Mobile
Web Kit? I don't have a good answer for you
on the Web Kit front. I do know it is available
in FireFox right now. You can download FireFox
for those machines and it will run WebGL.
I have been told that it's not -- you know,
it is still very beta and there is not performance
optimize there yet, but it does work. I have
seen demos come up.
>>> Okay, great, thanks.
>>Gregg Tavares: I actually -- yeah. I actually
have seen it running in Web Kit in certain
places. But when it would be available, I
have no idea.
>>> There's been a bit of press about security
vulnerabilities exposed by WebGL. Are you
guys doing anything to address that?
>>Gregg Tavares: So the question is there's
been some security vulnerabilities that just
came out, I think it was yesterday, in WebGL
and what are we doing to address that. We
are taking that seriously. Obviously Chrome's
main thing is that we are all about security.
Chrome in particular, we actually run all
of our GPU processing in a separate process.
So, like, we do for other things, even if
somehow a Web page was able to execute code
in the process that actually runs your Web
page, it is not allowed to call GL at all.
Or at least if it does call it, it can't call
it with any parameters that we don't approve.
That said, we are taking it very seriously.
We are talking -- we are with the Chronos
group and discussing it with the other browser
vendors to decide what to do. We are working
with the driver manufacturers to make sure
all these issues are covered because they
know up until this point, it has always been
you installed an app and you trusted that
app when you installed it.
And it is changing to this new Web model where
things are supposed to be not trusted and
you just have to make yourself secure. So
we file every bug we can. We blacklist any
card we find that has a problem.
That's why so many cards are blacklisted right
now. Any card before 2009, January 2009, is
blacklisted and other one that is we find
bugs in.
>>> Okay, thank you.
>>Gregg Tavares: Any other questions?
(Speaker off microphone.)
>>Gregg Tavares: So the question was what's
the performance penalty for the Sandbox in
Chrome? We are actually not sure.
My personal opinion is that we actually run
faster. And the reason is that we are, basically,
multi-processing your app because what we
do is we take all your WebGL calls and we
serialize them through a command buffer. That
actually get called by another process. And
that means your WebGL code is able to issue
them much faster than it could without that.
And then some other process is able to spend
the time doing the hard work.
There are issues we have. We have flow control
issues we keep working on, that we get more
speed and add something else and then we break
that and get a little less speed. Ultimately,
we should be able to run faster because of
our Sandbox, not slower.
Any other questions? All right. Thank you
very much.
[ Applause ]